[Música]
i
aunque los más recientes indicadores
parece señalar que el pico de la
pandemia ha pasado ya en el áfrica
sub-sahariana hay otros índices mortales
que están disparando las alarmas en la
región es el caso de la tuberculosis que
dará las interrupciones en los sistemas
de salud podría causar hasta 6 millones
de muertes en los próximos años el vih
es otra enfermedad que aquí en el sur de
áfrica tiene uno de los índices más
altos en el mundo y se calcula que más o
menos la tercera parte de la población
que sufre de vih aparece también de
tuberculosis y esto podría reflejarse en
unas 500 mil muertes adicionales en los
próximos dos años por causas
relacionadas al vih otro caso muy
preocupante es la malaria que causa
miles de muertes en todo el continente
cada año pero sólo en angola por poner
un ejemplo la malaria es la principal
causa de muerte en la población y este
año he registrado ya un millón y medio
de casos y unas 4.000 muertes finalmente
a sudáfrica está registrando un 60%
adicional de muertes por causa natural y
esto está poniendo en duda las cifras
oficiales de lo que se registra por
muertes por kobe 19 acá en el país
[Música]
el cohete 19 ha aumentado los decesos en
europa de eso no cabe duda pero está
lejos de ser la principal causa de
muerte en el viejo continente según el
eurostat del año 2016 la principal causa
de fallecimiento en el viejo continente
son las enfermedades circulatorias que
afectaron a un 36 por ciento de los
fallecidos esto es 18 millones de
personas en segundo lugar se ubica el
cáncer que afectó a un 26 por ciento de
los fallecidos
esto es 1,3 millones de europeos sólo en
el quinto lugar se encuentran las
enfermedades digestivas que causaron la
muerte de 222 mil personas su efecto es
comparable con el del coi 19 que hasta
la fecha deja según la oms 215 mil 387
fallecidos en la unión europea la
sobremortalidad ligada al coi 19
afectado más algunos países como el
reino unido italia españa y francia y en
cambio ha provocado una disminución en
los decesos en países como bulgaria
noruega y eslovaquia
[Música]
destapar un agujero para tapar otro los
esfuerzos para frenar el cob y 19 son
necesarios sin embargo organismos
internacionales denuncian el olvido
hacia otras enfermedades mortales los
motivos los programas de prevención se
han suspendido se han cerrado clínicas y
en muchos países se ha paralizado el
reparto de anticonceptivos en el caso de
la tuberculosis organizaciones denuncian
que no pueden ir a registrar casos a
comunidades densamente pobladas como las
favelas en río de janeiro o lugares
remotos como la selva en mexico
similares lo que sucede con el vih que
afecta a más de 2 millones de personas
en la región por ejemplo preocupa el
futuro en ecuador el 64% de hombres y el
54% de mujeres han dejado de usar
métodos anticonceptivos significativa es
también la afectación de enfermedades
derivadas por los mosquitos los
servicios de salud han reducido su
respuesta a enfermedades como el dengue
el cica la chikungunya o la malaria esta
enfermedad afecta especialmente a las
comunidades indígenas como demuestran
los datos de panamá donde el 90% de los
casos de los últimos 10 años fueron en
estas comunidades
[Música]